let's go next - oh you know who we
haven't heard from from a while we
haven't heard from Milo for a little
while
Milo from the nine one seven what's
going on Milo hey David how you doing
good how are you pretty good first I
actually just wanted to ask out of
curiosity because I uh I know you're
Jewish are you fasting today of any
chance no no no no oh okay yeah anyway
so my question is more broadly speaking
it's about pro-worker
policies but to sort of contextualize
the question a little bit I want to give
a quick anecdote so about three months
ago I was on a trip to France with a few
family members and on the on the way
back we were in the airport in Paris and
I was waiting in line with my father and
he's like a scent he's like a waffle a
centrist kind of guy and as soon as we
got as we got closer to the line so we
were waiting in line for about an hour
and a half two hours and as we got
further towards the front of the line
the reason why we realized it was taking
so long was because there were only
about one or two TSA workers sitting at
the desk to help us check our baggage
and okay hold on can we back understand
a hold can we let me let me just back up
a little bit so I can understand the
story you're you're in Paris this is
happening in Paris right yeah okay so
you're saying it's not so TSA doesn't
check bags and they only are in the US
are you talking about there were only
two airline employees checking people in
yeah just like the people who sit you
know behind the desk like towards and
the entrance to the airport where we
like to check our baggage okay got it
these were not security people these
were airline employees checking people
in and checking bags correct yeah okay
all right they were only two lines
moving really slow very common
particularly in European airports yes
yeah yeah yeah because like the the
point that my dad made was like under
like a Bernie presidency or whatever
like
like all of America would be like that
because like I think the point he was
trying to make was like when workers
have more rights because like France is
a really Pro worker country Bernie's a
really Pro worker guy like they have
more autonomy and they're more likely to
like spend their time in ways that are
like inconvenience to customers so I'm
just curious like what's like your take
on that I mean I don't know if you've
noticed but it's not like American based
airlines are known for having
particularly good service I'm less
exposed to it because in the u.s.
between I'm never checking a bag and I
have TSA PreCheck so like I never deal
with it but every time I go to Logan
Airport to fly anywhere the lines are
just as outrageous so I don't know I
mean it just it doesn't seem to really
compute for me it doesn't seem you know
he's saying that's though it's like that
in most of the world I don't know that
yeah it's just it doesn't seem like a
very solid argument to me see what your
take was on that so I appreciate taking
the call all right my look good to hear
from you appreciate the phone call